djm bar owner javier cruz is excited at
the prospect of reopening his listening
bar in bogota
waiting much longer could be the end of
the road for his business
as it has been for many others
[Music]
we are full of hope now but we must do
this with great caution and awareness
keeping many safety precautions in place
because we are still in a critical
moment and we need to take care of each
other
that's what the government hopes most
colombians will do as it bets on
reactivating all sectors of the economy
to try to respond to growing poverty and
unemployment
despite being in the midst of the worst
peak of the pandemic
more than 500 colombians are dying every
day
record numbers of infections are being
broken and intensive care
units are at capacity in all major
cities
even field hospitals set up to ease
pressure on the system are full
we've been at a very high plateau for
many weeks waiting for a reduction
but instead the figures keep climbing
for both infections and deaths
we're seeing major clusters due to the
social situation in the country
so things could get even worse because
the numbers show an exponential increase
much of the blame for the stubbornness
of this surge is focused on the ongoing
anti-government protests
authorities are using them to explain
the paradox of opening up
right when conditions are at their worst
in case we could stay at home in strict
quarantine throughout the city
but the infections have already occurred
with or without opening we will have two
to three weeks with high occupancy
the government is confident that a
faster pace of vaccinations will help
improve the health situation in the
country in coming weeks
but a number of doctors associations say
that the decision to reopen
now is reckless
the government's decision isn't based on
science many doctors and academics have
been studying the decree
and we can't find validity to their
arguments that's why we're asking for it
to be repealed
it's a paradox we're pushing our society
towards an even worse tragedy
than the ones we're already living
concerts and dance clubs will remain
closed until
icu's occupancy falls under 85 percent
the rest of the restrictions are now
gone with colombians left
wondering if they will be able to strike
a balance
between the need to work and the need to
save lives
alessandra ampietti al jazeera bogota